hello everyone and welcome to another
fine game from round 10 of the 2021 tata
still chess tournament it's andre
estipaenko versus david anton guiharo
is having an amazing tournament he is
the only
player to defeat magnus carlsen so far
and he has
some very very good chances on actually
winning the event but we're going to
talk a little bit about
about that after we check out this game
so he has the white pieces and as the
title suggests
this is a very very closed game so
without further ado let's check it out
esepenco
uh opens with e4 with e5 knight to f3
knight to c6 and the bishop to b5 uh the
real lopez is on the board we have
a6 morpheus defense and now bishop to a4
knight to f6 and now castles and like we
said it's going to be a very very close
position so bishop to e7
uh d3 uh and now b5 pushing back the
bishop bishop to b3 and now d6
and here the most common idea is just to
go a4 as
black gave you some targets here on the
queen side but here
uh just the very very uh slow bishop to
d2 and it's not a new move
uh it has been played before we have
bishop to g4
black develops the bishop pins the
knight and now c3
and here there are some moves where
knight the a5 uh
where knight's day 5 was played also
castles is a known move in this position
but bishop to h5 by guiharo
is a new move so that already as of move
nine we have a completely new game
so let's see uh how the game continues
rook to e1
just uh making room uh just uh getting
rooked to that open e file at some point
you want to play bishop
to c2 maybe even bust open with d4 and
the rook will
do a very nice job from e1 so knight to
a5
again a standard maneuver black moves
the knight attacks the bishop
wants to advance the pawn all the way to
c5 so bishop back to c2
white of course not interested in giving
up this bishop for a knight and now
c5 with h3 and black castles and now
even bishop to c1 the queen will also be
very useful
on the d file knight back to c6 and not
knight b
to d2 going for the standard knight to
f1 for example the g3 maneuver
and the black takes this opportunity to
strike in the center because
you have this backwards d6 pawn if you
can get rid of it without
messing up your position it's definitely
what you should do and here uh david
anton goes for d5
uh black not interested white not
interested in capturing
as that would only improve uh the
position of of black's pieces so knight
to f1
white just continues with his plan and
now even d4
so uh uh not allowing this bishop to
gain any activity for the moment this d3
pawn is a
somewhat of a problem for for white and
maybe black can even attack it
afterwards so here we have knights the
g3 attacking the bishop bishop to g6 and
now
bishop to d2 so just continuing
development
both players just looking for optimal
squares for their pieces
so rook to e rook to c8 and now rook to
c1
we have rook to e8 and now queen to e2
you have to develop the queen somewhere
you also want to connect your rooks but
uh there aren't all that many squares so
here white is thinking
why not queen to f1 uh black goes bishop
to f8 and now
queen to f1 and we could say that uh
after queen to d6 the
both sides kind of finish development
but they will of course
still be looking for even more optimal
squares with rook c
to d1 and queen back to d7
and now comes knight to h4 with ideas of
maybe capturing the bishop
but also now both of the knights have
access to the f5 square so black will
always have to take this into
consideration
uh queen back to d8 and now knight g
to f5 and here uh black needs to decide
how to continue uh with the game here so
there is a very straightforward line
that starts with just capturing the
knight i will show it
as it it kind of does make sense for
example captures captures in g6 now you
either
push back the knight or white goes for
this trade knight h6 check
captures captures uh and now only now
you capture on c3 to gain a new target
uh b captures and queen to a5 with a
double attack on these pawns so this is
a
one way to go about the position uh but
it's kind of saying uh okay
i give up the dark square bishop white
has a dark square bishop will i be able
to survive this f4 is coming the
position might open up
it's gonna be maybe a passive position
to play even if i do win a pawn on the
queen side
so black uh not interested in that goes
knight to d7
frees up the f6 square for the queen and
here queen
back to e2 now the queen can also help
out with queen to g4
if needed we have queen to f6 and now
rogue back to c1
we have knights to b6 and here um
a lot of ideas are possible you could
capture on d4 which is always an option
you could play queen f3 queen to g for
get the queen into the game
uh but here uh esipenko goes for this
c4 idea and now uh it's uh
it's a very very tricky move because
black
can just capture and he gets a past the
d-pawn so what's the idea behind this
let's see how the game continues and now
b captures on c4 so it's only as of move
26 that we have our first capture in the
game
so b captures on c4 d captures and c for
black now has a past pawn
and now rook b8 just going uh
putting a rook on this semi open b file
will be very useful
g3 by white and now knight to b4 uh
putting pressure on the bishop attacking
the a2 pawn bishop to b1 defending the
a2 pawn
and now knight back to c8 the knight can
now be remaneuvered
depending on what white plays but you
can bring it here maybe trade off
everything here you can bring it here
and then to c6 also an interesting idea
so all depending on what white plays so
here is panko goes for
knight captures on g6 h captures and
knight
back to h4 uh preparing to shift the
knight back to f3
we have queen to e6 and now uh king to
g2 as the h3 pawn is under attack so
king to g2
and now knight to d6 uh we have knight
to f3
and now uh bishop to e7 uh and finally
a3 king with that
black knight from from b4 we have knight
back to c6
and now b4 so what's essipenko's idea
here as the b4 square is defended three
times well he wants black to capture and
then
advance c5 so c captures on b4 this is
not a forced capture you could also just
wait and and see
what happens uh but uh uh davinaton
decides to capture on b4 we have
c5 now now white also has a pass pawn
uh knight to b5 and only now a captures
on b4 for the moment
this knight is blocking uh this rook's
uh
uh uh approach to the b4 pawn but also
it's kind of saving
the black a6 pawn so here bishop to f6
and now
bishop to d3 putting more pressure on
this uh diagonal here
knight the c3 with an attack on the
queen and here uh white characters we
have bishop captures
d captures and now not capturing right
away because then you also allow knight
captures on b4
but instead after the captures on c3
first bishop to c4 with the idea of
improving the position of the bishop
with maybe bishop to d5
so queen to e7 and only now rook
captures on c3
we have rook captures on b4 and now
bishop to d5
attacks the knight the knight is
undefended but also you are picking up
the a6 pawn so it is
in fact white who will end up this
little skirmish being up upon and a
beautiful past
c pawn that's all there already very far
advanced
so knight to d4 and now finally queen
captures on a6 leaving white with this
pass pawn
and it's going to be very hard for black
to deal with this queen to c7
setting up a blockade anymore defense
that e5 pawn and now
knight captures on d4 e captures on d4
and rook back to c2 uh we have g5 by
white not
allowing the immediate f4 and now queen
back to d3 and here white has a
beautiful position
a much better position he just needs to
put his pieces on optimal squares and
then figure out how he's going to push
that c
pawn to victory so bishop e5 and now
rook to a1 now the rook can go up the
board you can maybe go rook to a6 then
push the pawn
and then see how how you're gonna do it
you can double up rooks
on the fi a file if possible uh not for
the moment as the queen is attacking the
c5 pawn but black needs to play
something
and depending on what black plays you
are going to figure out what you're
going to do so here
queen to e7 uh black makes one move but
uh now he also allows white to this very
nice rook lift
rook to a6 we have rook back to f8
uh this pawn might require additional
protection later on
and now c6 just continues pushing that
past pawn
uh we have rook beat the b8 bringing the
rook back to help out help out with the
defense and now
rook c to e2 uh sorry uh
rook rook c to a2 uh and now rook
b the c8 so uh creating sort of a
blockade here but now comes
rook to a7 attacking the queen rook to
c7 blocking
and now you could capture the rook for
example captures captures and then play
rook b2 with the idea of bringing the
other rook into the game
or you could play uh what ac pink played
which is just
rook here to b7 and now if black trades
you already get a pass pawn on b7 and
otherwise you are planning
rook a to a7 which will then create a
lot of problems for black
so here g6 by david anton and now
queen to d2 we have a rook
f the c8 doubling up on the c file and
now of course
you capture on c7 rook captures rook
captures
uh and now h4 h4 with a very
uh direct idea of opening up uh
the diagonal for the queen to use so
here g captures on h4 was played but
even if you don't capture there aren't
aren't any good moves in this position
now white is completely winning but you
have to be kind of precise
so feel free to pause the video here and
win this game for espanko
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding
a move other than rook to a8 even though
rook a8 is perfectly fine you will
probably eventually win the game but
after this check and king moves
there's just no good way to continue the
attack so you might not want to allow
black
any any resources and of course for
those of you who found queen to h6
congratulations as this is now
game over and it was in fact in this
position that david anton guiharo
resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done
there are simply too many threats rook
to a8 is one of them
and if you defend it let's say rook to
c8 then again
you get queen to g6 with check kind of
the point of queen to h6 the queen
cannot be captured due to the pin
and after king to f8 you can just
continue
playing you're now you've grabbed
another pawn for example queen f5
goes after the rook and after you save
the rook now even
f4 bishop has to go somewhere you're
gonna play g
captures on h4 and black is without a
move you are just pushing this
past h pawn to victory uh the pawn
cannot be captured black always needs to
attend to this checkmating idea on f7
and other than that black
really has no moves uh like really
really no moves
it would be it would be impossible to
even think of a move here
so that's uh that that's really bad
position and of course david anton
resigned here
so brilliant victory foreign who is
doing an amazing job this tournament
like we said
and i think he has maybe even the
biggest
chance of winning this event because uh
he already played against all of the top
guys so uh
now he only has left uh van forest
donchenko and arientari and
of course they are not easy opponents
but uh it's better than having for
example
fabi uh carlson and mvl for your last
three opponents so
uh he definitely has chances to win the
event and it would be it would be
extremely impressive if he uh was able
to do that uh
just win an event that magnus is playing
in while also beating magnus in this
event
and uh so we don't forget we promised
that we were going to show the standings
so these are the standings after round
ten uh first place with seven out of ten
anichigiri then with six and a half uh
andre sipenko fabiano karwana and
alireza faruja with six jordan run
forest
magnus is on five and a half so a full
point and a half behind anish giri
with five uh pentala hari krishna niels
grandelius with four
young [ __ ] of duda maxine vashila grav
and aryanthari
alexander with three out of ten and
donchenko was uh
really sad this round because he played
against mvl he got a winning position
against mvl and then
mvl was just you know you know he curled
up like like a turtle he defended defend
the defender defended
uh and then in the end they equalized
and then even won the game
in in a position that was supposed to be
a table based draw
uh but yeah if nvl lost that one it'd be
it'd be uh probably the worst event
envel played
since he was like maybe 15 years old i
don't know but but i don't think he
he had an event this bad for a very long
time
but okay three more rounds to go so he
might win all of his next three games
we'll see how it goes
uh but yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it tomorrow the
the clash everyone's been waiting for
anishigiri will face magnus carlsen
uh aguirre with the black pieces and he
needs uh to do well
to stay a contender to to win the
tournament uh but yeah i would like to
thank tony moa guitar uh ante wetman
rodrigo alves a staff and pavel pillar
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and
i will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of the tata steel checking up
on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day
and tomorrow probably tomorrow morning
we are
uploading the uh the london system
tutorial how to play against it uh thank
y'all uh and see you soon guys